I guess I'll be heading home catching
the number 12 bus to Satan's butthole
actually I prefer the number 69 train to
humpsville station
my wife is back no kidding Donna not her
the other ex-wife
Tammy won she's in your office
this could end up being the best night
in Ron Swanson's life I am so so happy
for him hello you gorgeous Craftsman
wow look at this room so much wood ready
to be worked
me alert alert alert alert
she's here isn't she
fun
dream you'd be
Tammy this
is this Diane this is a piece of human
garbage named Tammy who is also my
ex-wife tricex wife we were married
twice and divorced twice everything is
done they're totally done Tammy what are
you doing here oh I just have a little
something I need to get drilled
hey Jer Bear what are you doing with
these two jabronis Tammy I've given this
a lot of thought
we should break up
what's the matter little boy did the bad
people get to you they just made me
realize how unhealthy this is literally
all the steak and whiskey I have to wear
a diaper gosh because you're my little
baby we drilled you on this Jam baby
talk what do you do
I'm not a baby I'm a big boy
yeah okay well that wasn't terrible
don't listen to Leslie she's trying to
manipulate you all she cares about is
herself and I can prove it how's this
Leslie
you leave us alone and we swing the vote
to you help you get your Park
no nice try stay strong Jeremy
it's over Tammy tell you what it's been
long enough
what do you say we
consummate our relationship
tonight
huh let's do it
and the last card is played what are you
doing shh this is a library
Ron I need that crotch Blinder no you
don't just end it
look at my boobs no look downstairs no
there's a prize inside for you it's over
Tammy
to hell with you woman goodbye
dear you are you okay me you'll be back
they all come back well done Jeremy
turns out the cross Blinder was inside
you all alone
naked I'm Leslie are you Chris yeah
sorry I'm late oh don't worry about it
you look beautiful thank you oh here let
me take your coat thanks
sure I actually heard that what well I
went to Wisconsin for both undergrad and
grad school
go Badgers boo Indiana Hoosiers no
Badgers
oh
it's not important I'm just glad that we
could make this happen and kept going on
about how wonderful you are and I just
had to see for myself well she's my
number one best friend I wish she told
me that you went to Indiana but whatever
so you're in charge of amusement parks
right oh that's exciting actually
regular parks
like swings and slides and stuff strike
two
you know isn't it funny how these setups
are always just so awkward
okay
hey watch this
I will now extinguish this candle with
my bare hand
okay
ah that really hurts are you okay oh God
it looks so much easier on the internet
God I gotta borrow some advice
so do you enjoy it
being an MRI technician great question
someone steps into the room
imagine a mother of three maybe she's a
teacher she knows something's wrong but
you're scared
in less than an hour
I know what it is what's wrong with her
I don't know but the best part about
being an MRI technician is
I can see inside everything
see that guy over there imagine being
able to look inside his head wow I know
look inside the steak or this butter or
this bread you can look inside
anything well if you look inside this
bread all you're gonna find is more
bread I don't know I'd have to do an MRI
it's good that you found your calling I
mean I've never even
I don't know about this
I'm offering you a free scan usually
costs up to two thousand dollars
kind of spoiling you here
well I am a little curious good
frankly I don't want to invest in
someone who only has three months to
live
oh I'm just trying to think of this as
an adventure you know just getting right
back on that horse
even if that horse is crazy and wants to
peer inside my body
how does that feel uh weird perfect
oh not on your period are you no does
that matter well not for this
okay it's gonna be a little cramped in
there don't worry I'll be right on the
other side of that glass
so you never told me where you're from
I'm from Pawnee keep still please
what kind of music do you like
can I answer that sure keep still
all kinds
very important that you keep still at
this moment Leslie I've told you that a
thousand times
did you ever break your arm you can
answer that here I'll turn it off
we're gonna turn the machine off for
that
you never had any kids right Leslie
you've got a great oven okay
ample room in there honestly if you
wanted to you could go triplets right
off the bat Leslie you got a big
industrial sized oven so we're done
right
cool again Northwestern I studied
semiotics wrote a thesis on narrative
forms in the digital world then you
became a morning shock jock and created
the sport taint ball
yeah you know the douche Persona is
something I came up with during college
it started as satire and you know we
snowballed to where we are today I mean
I know it's a silly thing to do but it
pays the bills well I think you probably
need to get back to the studio play some
far
actually affording immigrants segment
would be really funny
at all good looking out Leslie if you
guys ever want to do this again the
souls clothing give me a shout gross
that was the douche talking honestly
good luck on this project it sounds
really interesting I'm gonna scan a
quick pick and then boobies for a little
deposit in El Banco de spanco that was
the douche talking douche Nation you
guys know where the library is
wow douche hey douche
councilman Hauser councilwoman no what's
up Leslie you want to Funk this junk in
the back of my trunk that was the douche
talking okay look Ann is not
interviewing you for her blog she's
thinking about having a baby and she's
considering you as a possible donor
wow you know
thought a lot about having kids it's the
next big step in this Grand Adventure
that we call Life frankly I don't think
you would be the right man for the job
well frankly I don't think it's for you
to decide you know if we had a little
girl I would name her Elizabeth after my
grandmother she was the strong amazing
woman if we had a boy I don't know I'd
name him something funny like dick or OJ
because I have a lot to consider my God
I have driven Anne right into the belly
of the douche
hey what's up oh nothing I was listening
to the radio on my way here and I heard
something very interesting so crazy Ira
remember that chick and I used to
she was smoking huh
turns out she wants to have my baby
anyway her lesbo friend tells me she's
on the prowl for some baby beans and
it's down to me and some other turd
munchers
wow
you should be angry I can't believe
Howard did that to you